thil à munich le grand jour du massacre
des citrouilles est arrivée la fameuse
fête d'halloween
elle vient de chez nous très ancienne
coutume celtes et les partis aux états
unis et puis comme souvent ça s'en va et
ça revient
déguisements petit rond fait pour les
enfants et business
nicolas winckler delphine detry il ya
dix ans personne en france ne fais tu es
vraiment halloween aujourd'hui pourtant
vous serez des millions à jouer à shérif
fais moi peur
halloween est désormais devenue une
incontournable fête populaire
l'histoire commence là vous achats se
termine au tiroir-caisse il ya six ans
une grande enseigne de jouets décide de
lancer la mode et la surprise ce n'est
pas un succès c'est un raz-de-marée les
jeunes générations abreuver de cinéma de
cultures américaines connaissent déjà
tous d'halloween les commerçants
s'aperçoit avec stupeur qu'il dormait
sans le savoir sur un immense tas d'or
il ya un petit peu de ça voilà un petit
peu de ça donc je pense qu'on s'est
réveillé on s'est réveillé malgré tout
dans les premiers donc on n'a pas dû
dormir trop longtemps mais mais c'est
vrai que les consommateurs attendaient
attendait surtout une offre produit
originale et amusante emballé le légume
dans un carton avec un kit de découpage
et voilà comment la citrouille dont on
suit contenter de faire des soupes est
devenu un produit à la mode vendu près
de 50 francs au supermarché
inutile de dire qu à rungis on se frotte
les mains depuis trois ans
production de ses fruits a augmenté de
30% aujourd'hui on a trente mille tonnes
donc une croissance exceptionnelle en
matière de fruits et légumes du jamais
vu à rungis du jamais vu non plus dans
les agences de marketing halloween c'est
l'occasion rêvée pour rajeunir son image
de marque à un moment de l'année qui
était jusque-là traditionnellement un
creux douloureux avant noël c'est
forcément creuse pour les marketeurs
parce qu'on rentre la rentrée qui tu es
une grosse boom n'est rien en france
devant nos produits
un alibi désormais partagée par des
milliers de commerçants et d'industriels
mais halloween qui était peut-être au
départ une affaire de gros sous et
devenu n'en déplaise à certains une fête
familiale et populaire
un phénomène encore plus marquée en
province qu'à paris
halloween vient d'abord de province ça
c'est fait et très très fortement ça se
sont très fortement dans toute la
province et ensuite c'est remonter à
paris mais pour faire che coach pour
frapper au porte et demander des bonbons
à paris faut avoir le code est entré
dans les immeubles avec le code d'entrée
de la maison le code de la chance heures
ça devient vraiment compliqué les
enfants se fiche pas mal que certains
voient dans le succès d' halloween une
victoire de la world compagny fête
païenne par excellence halloween est
désormais durablement ancré dans les
habitudes et pour la première fois dans
le journal de 13h un journaliste masqué
s'avance nicolas falquet remercie de
nous avoir rejoints
c'est par respect dopage oh oui c'est
pas de le paix aux usa d'où ça vient
cette fête d'halloween l'origine elle et
elle est celle qui c'était ils étaient
installés quelque part en hongrie à 3000
ans trois mineurs avant jésus-christ
puis ils ont migré petit à petit vers
l'europe de l'ouest y compris en irlande
et c'est celle qu'il avait un nouvel an
celte c'était le 31 octobre qui marquait
le passage est bien
des de la saison chaude à la saison
froide c'est une fête religieuse
extrêmement importante et puis qui s'est
perpétuée jusque là pendant cette fête
les morts rendait visite aux vivants
parce qu'il faut savoir que l'excellent
croyait en la réincarnation et les
vivants se déguisait se grimer pour pas
que les morgues des reconnaissent et
geignard jouer des mauvais tours où elle
a ensuite les irlandais ont embarqué ça
aux états unis là bas c'est devenu une
immense fête avec des déguisements
puisse est revenue en france alors ses
revenues avec la citrouille pourquoi la
citrouille
c'est rue parce qu'à la base le feu
sacré et s était dans un navet qui était
creusé à l'intérieur et puis alors que
ça va donc les irlandais sont partis
pour comme c'est une énorme famine due
aux maladies de la patate
il arrive aux états unis et la caisse
qui découvrent et découvre la citrouille
beaucoup plus facile et rigolote à
creuser voilà pourquoi la tradition
appris de cette phase et à la
maintenance est vraiment devenu du
business on disait tout à l'heure et on
le voit avec vous là vous avez amené
plein de trucs fabriqué pour halloween
où elle vend on dit qu'on a vu dans ce
sujet que sa belle-fille quinquis est
étonnant c'est un inventeur d'objets au
fond c'est quelqu'un outre ce petit
bouquin ce petit guide qui l'a écrit les
cafés serrés très bien fichu
il a créé des produits autour
d'halloween dont certains marchent très
fort comme cela que vous allez retrouver
dans la grande distribution qui est une
limonade avec de la citrouille dedans
alors je vous permettre de vous faire
goûter sa couleur c'est une drôle de
couleur c'est l'hymne à la citrouille
zighout et ça fait d'être sur les
chaussures quand on te dit ouais je
suppose blu ray alors vous avez aussi
des des petits bonbons comme ça et puis
il en prit alors les trous dans
l'estomac puis vous avez ce gâteau je
vais essayer de l'allumer vous allez
voir c'est très rigolo aussi vous
l'allumez sas et hop on éteint la
lumière du plateau et on voit en théorie
des citrouilles apparaître si là il ya
quelques années me verse en voulait il
faisait la tournée des des boulangers
pour essayer de vendre sa personne
voulait il faut voir aujourd'hui le
succès de succès que c'est à quel point
ça a pris alors tout le monde
pratiquement est heureux les marchands
et les enfants il y a quand même des
gens qui ne sont pas très contents
ce sont la hiérarchie assez la
hiérarchie catholique monseigneur louis
marie billet vous êtes en direct avec
nous depuis lyon merci d'être avec nous
président de la conférence des évêques
de france archevêque de lyon
pourquoi vous n'aimez pas les
citrouilles dans le potage aime beaucoup
ça et ceci depuis longtemps je crois
simplement que ni les questions de
cuisine ni le succès commercial ni le
parcours historique très intéressant
qu'on nous a fait faire il y a un an
ce temps ne doivent pas masquer un
certain nombre d'enjeux sur le plan
culturel sur le plan du sens de la vie
sur le plan religieux pour les enfants
que l'on fait jouer mais qu en faisant
jouer on exploite peut-être quelque peu
quand vous dites vous c'est un rite
païen et c'est donc dangereux pour les
enfants c'est ça c'est pernicieux
ah c'est aller un petit peu vite en
besogne pour ma part cela fait des
dizaines d'années qu'à la toussaint je
vis une fête de la joie de la relation
entre les vivants de cette terre et les
hommes et les femmes qui vivent auprès
de dieu je vis une fête de l'espérance
de la communion de l'amour et voilà que
tout d'un coup je me retrouve
je vais vous à gérer un peu environné de
citrouille de squelettes de sorcières de
fantômes ou de fantasmes de toutes
sortes et très honnêtement je
m'interroge
une chose est de permettre aux enfants
de jouer de les laisser jouer autre
chose de les faire jouer avec ces
choses-là
si ça marche si bien c'est probablement
que halloween met en jeu des ressorts
profonds de la psychologie et de la vie
humaine et il faut que l'on accepte de
regarder comment ces ressorts on les
traite de regarder ce que l'on en fait
en fait ce qu'est ce qui vous gêne
monseigneur c'est que ce soit tout
proche de l'as de la toussaint parce que
par exemple le mardi gras quand on se
déguise ça c'est plutôt sympathique non
là c'est parce que ça fait concurrence à
la toussaint non je ne suis pas dans une
perspective de concurrence d'ailleurs
vous pourrez venir demain si vous voulez
à la cathédrale saint-jean à lyon et
vous verrez qu'il y aura beaucoup
d'hommes de femmes de jeunes a fêté avec
bonheur la fête de la toussaint
ce qui me gêne c'est que l'on ne regarde
pas les enjeux de ce qui se passe dans
une société où on occulte la mort ou
point où on le fait que se passe-t-il
lorsqu'on se met tout d'un coup
à se faire peur avec la mort lorsque on
se met à tourner la mort en dérision et
j'allais dire à jouer avec la mort je
crois quand même que cela ne peut pas
être aussi innocent que l'on veut bien
le dire
il y a deux jours où on m'a montré par
exemple le sujet est un peu différent
mais c'est le même une carte de démons
officiel que telle entreprise injures
sial c'est un jeu de joie des enfants
il y à diverses manières de jouer et
encore une fois je crois que ce n'est
pas la même chose que d'accompagner un
jeu d'enfant et de faire jouer des
enfants à notre manière à nous merci
monseigneur pour c'est pour ces
précisions
petit point